bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous
regarde en direct ravi de vous retrouver
au sommaire ce soir un grand débat
spécial sur l'énergie au coeur de la
guerre en ukraine avec pour commencer
cette question doit-on se passer du gaz
et du pétrole russes comme l'ont décidé
hier les américains la pression monte
sur l'union européenne les vingt-sept se
retrouvent demain à versailles pour en
discuter si cette guerre nous imposer
finalement la sobriété énergétique à
marche forcée on en parle dans un
instant avec nos invités on va s'arrêter
aussi sur cette phrase choc si et bruno
le maire la crise énergétique est
comparable au choc pétrolier de 1973
l'invasion russe en ukraine se ressent
déjà dans les stations-service de prix à
la pompe a dépassé les 2 euros alors
jusqu'où va baisser notre pouvoir
d'achat à quoi peut-on s'attendre
quelles réponses politiques l'analyse de
nos d'experts sur ce plateau enfin j -30
2 avant le premier tour et oui déjà
nouveau rendez-vous dans le scan ce soir
on va parler notamment de l'accueil des
réfugiés ukrainien qui bouscule la
course à l'elysée puis nouveau rendez
vous bien un visage familier l'oeil de
blacko bien sûr le carnet de campagne
signée stéphane blakowski ce sera tout à
l'heure rester avec nous cela vaut
perdre ses mains
[Musique]
on
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'être au
rendez-vous le gaz russe a aujourd'hui
l'odeur du sang l'ukrainien voilà ce
qu'a déclaré le ministre ukrainien des
affaires étrangères il ya quelques jours
alors peut-on encore se permettre
d'acheter du gaz et du pétrole avaient
des mires poutine pour financer sa
guerre ce sont des questions importantes
elle son moral elles sont aussi
complexes et vous voulez pose ce soir
mode brégeon bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes porte parole de la
république en marche pour soir anna
créty et merci d'être avec nous cet
économiste spécialiste des questions
énergétiques vous dirigez la chaire
économie du gaz naturel et du climat à
l'université paris dauphine enfin bon
soir yves marignac bonsoir et bienvenue
porte parole de l'association un
négawatt qui milite pour la transition
écologique quand on parlera pouvoir
d'achat un peu plus tard dans ce débat
on accueillera anne-sophie al cif qui
est prévisionniste au bureau
d'information et de prévisions
économiques peut-on se passer du gaz
russe avant de vous entendre on va faire
le point sur notre dépendance à la
russie sur les énergies fossiles avec
nicolas coadou au 14e jour de la guerre
en ukraine sur le front énergétique
l'annnonce de nouvelles sanctions venus
d'outre-atlantique est tombée comme un
couperet nous bannissons le gaz le
pétrole et l'énergie russe mais l'europe
peut-elle salué sur son allié américain
et se passer des énergies russe sur le
papier ça semble compliqué l'année
dernière l'europe a acheté beaucoup de
gaz russe 140 milliards de mètres cubes
via ses gazoducs 15 milliards de gaz
naturel liquéfié acheminé par bateau au
total plus de 40 % de nos besoins une
facture de 10 milliards d'euros par mois
en moyenne
mais il existe des différences entre
pays européens
si le gaz russe représente 55% des
importations allemandes c'est seulement
17 % pour la france si l'europe ou la
russie en venait à couper les vannes le
vieux continent pourrait se tourner vers
la norvège a qui fournit déjà un quart
du gaz européen vers l'algérie ou encore
vers d'autres pays plus éloignés mais
les volumes serait loin d'être suffisant
tous les producteurs en ce moment au 10
au maximum de leurs capacités
il n'y a pas de producteurs qui aurait
souligné de la production de gaz gazeux
ou qualité en se disant mais j'attendais
qui est une grosse crise pouvoir aux
médecins marché reste le pétrole
l'annnonce du boycott américain a fait
bondir le baril de brent et à la pompe
les prix bat des records en europe un
quart du pétrole importé et russes avec
une grande disparité entre les pays mais
en cas de pénurie il existe une
solidarité entre états membres de l'ue
l'union européenne est prête aujourd'hui
a décidé un embargo pétrolier contre la
russie ce que propose la commission
européenne
c'est à l'horizon 2030 l'union
européenne puisse se passer complètement
julie bien complètement du pétrole et du
gaz à plus court terme la commission
européenne souhaite réduire sa
dépendance aux énergies russe de deux
tiers d'ici la fin de l'année outre la
diversification des importations restent
plusieurs options comme tout simplement
utiliser moins de gaz ou encore
développer le recours aux énergies
renouvelables en europe certains pays
comme l'italie se disent même prêts à
rouvrir d'anciennes usines à charbon
autre option développer l'extraction de
gaz de schiste la france en possède la
deuxième réserve d'europe mais son
exploitation jugé destructrices pour
l'environnement est pour l'heure
interdite
alors voilà pour l'état des lieux avant
de savoir comment concrètement se
déprendre du gaz du pétrole russe et en
combien de temps moi j'ai une question
déjà en pensant aux ukrainiens - deux
régions est-ce que c'est pas la moindre
des choses qu'on leur doit tout
simplement arrêté arrêté de leur acheter
à poutine
le gaz et le pétrole pour financer cette
guerre je pense que c'est une nécessité
sauf qu'il est aujourd'hui plus facile
de dire ça quand vous vivez en france et
que 17 % environ en 2021 de votre mix
gazier vient de la russie c'est moins
facile de le dire quand vous êtes
allemand ou que vous vous habitez en
europe de l'est où vous dépendez
massivement denez russie l'ue et à
importer du gaz russe depuis même plus b
puis là la guerre en ce début je pense
que s'il ya une chose qu'on va tirer à
long terme de la guerre en ukraine c'est
l'implication les implications
géopolitiques en matière de dépendance
vis-à-vis d'autres pays des stratégies
énergétiques de chaque pays et de la
fortiori de l'union européenne et donc
ça rappelle cette absolue nécessité de
construire en européen une stratégie
énergétique qui nous abstraite cette
dépendance à la russie c'est ce que
porte le président de la république
notamment par exemple dans ce qui a été
annoncé à belfort dans cette volonté de
décarbonés l'industrie c'est aussi ce
qui doit être portée à l'échelle de
l'union européenne puisque on voit de
façon extrêmement concrète aujourd'hui
ce que ça implique dans les relations
géopolitiques dans le bras de fer qu'on
peut avoir avec vladimir poutine mais
aussi sur le pouvoir d'achat des gens
alors on va dire dans le détail à la
crypte et on va faire de la pédagogie
je vais vous montrer deux cartes on a
compris qu en europe dépendance était
très différente selon les pays
dépendance au gaz et au pétrole russe
mais là ça c'est pour le gaz est ce
qu'on peut voir la carte s'affiche et on
voit que c'est très très différents
selon les pays certains pays baltes
comme la lettonie 100% de gaz russe
importé la république tchèque également
l'allemagne l'allemagne est à plus de
60% comme on explique au fond que ces
pays là ce soit voilà livrer du gaz
russe quasiment totalement bah disons
que il ya deux raisons qui sont à la
fois
économique et historique
ce sont des pays qui étaient un peu
satellite de la russie donc qui était
une sorte de déboucher
sûr à 100% donc quand il était fait
partie du bloc on va dire de l'influencé
russe la question ne se posait même pas
la lettonie l'autriche la république
tchèque et après il y a eu aussi une
sorte de résistance au changement dans
la mesure où aussi historiquement les
gaz était une ressource abondante et
pêcheurs donc les
par inertie cette situation d'utiliser
d'utiliser les gaz après dans les
différentes filières qu'il s'agisse pour
les besoins thermiques ou les procédés
industriels ou encore la production
d'électricité c'est quelque chose voilà
qui sait quelques paris miss est un peu
dans les mix des pays et on sait très
bien qu'il s'agit aussi de
quand on parle de mix énergétique on a
quand même des gros investissements qui
sont qui sont derrière donc un capital
qu'il est difficile quelque part de
déconstruire et donc une résistance très
forte aux allemagne pour l'allemagne 60
% elle paye entre guillemets ces jeux se
dire la sortie du nucléaire c'est ça qui
fait qu'on est à 60 % des importations
russes je pense que il faut quand même
dire que le gaz a essayé d'avoir le
courage de faire une transition
énergétique dans lequel l'un peur est
mis à plat
les secteurs entiers et comment la
production d'énergie était plus ou moins
nationale or ils ont investi aussi
massivement dans les énergies
renouvelables et ils ont ensuite à
l'accident de fukushima
us cette idée de faire les moratoires
sur sur le nucléaire donc reste
effectivement les gaz et les charbons
les charbons va sortir pour des
impératifs du moins c'est ce qui a été
négocié à me parler parti des verts du
mix énergétique donc voila voila il
reste il reste le gaz pour très
rapidement sur le pétrole alors là c'est
un peu moins fort la dépendance moyenne
au pétrole russe voilà la carte mais on
voit encore que certains pays à l'est
sont très dépendants du pétrole elle
magne c'est moins là on est on est à 30
% mais certains pays vont jusqu'à 84 %
pour la lituanie là encore les mêmes
raisons
ce sont les mêmes raisons et aussi la
force de négociation de ces pays sur les
marchés internationaux
la différence entre le encore une fois
historique entre les pétrole et le gaz
c'est que les pétrole a été d'emblée une
commodité internationale sauf que il
faut aller négocier avec les pays
producteurs et dans le temps en fait cet
aspect un peu de négociation se faisait
d'étain est un bon moment où la filière
de l'énergie était un peu comme celle
qui est restée à un gars ce format est l
émanation même de la puissance
presque régaliennes de l'état et donc ce
n'est pas tellement
surprenant que des pays entre guillemets
fait blue gène n'ai pas eu cette
possibilité de diversification oui de
l'accord yves marignac on va faire un
peu de pédagogie passer les dossiers
techniques on a bien compris que les
dépendances était très différente selon
les pays que les américains pouvaient
tout à fait se permettre ça leur coûte
très peu finalement cet embargo par
rapport à l'union européenne quels
secteurs consomment le plus de gaz pour
rester sur le gaz alors en france en
tout cas c'est
l'industrie et les bâtiments le
chauffage
pour les particuliers le domestique si
si on veut vraiment donner une vision
globale des enjeux il faut quand même
préciser que la dépendance à la russie
elle touche aussi au niveau européen le
charbon et le l'uranium et des activités
nucléaires il faut préciser que les pays
qui sont moins dépendants de la russie
le sont d'autres importations fossiles
notamment des pétromonarchies du
moyen-orient par exemple
le vrai sujet c'est vraiment de de
réduire l'ensemble de mecs dépendance à
ces importations elles beaucoup du gaz
et géopolitique du gaz et du pétrole
russes la france par exemple importe
aussi de l'uranium pour faire marcher
ses centrales alors la france n'ont pas
directement et n'importe elle importe
tout son uranium évidemment mais pas
massivement de russie au niveau européen
au niveau européen c'est là qu'on a des
statistiques
précises
20% de l'uranium naturel qui entre dans
l'union européenne
venez en 2022 russie et environ 25% de
des services de ce qu'on appelle la
vente du combustible la conversion et
l'enrichissement de l'uranium pour les
différents réacteurs
fonctionnant en europe 25 % environ et
est fournie par part aux atomes en
russie donc cette dépendance existe et
il ya même 18 réacteurs dont l'union
européenne à l'est évidemment qui sont
des réacteurs aujourd'hui de conception
soviétique
et donc est donc luce alors la pression
elle est là parce que joe biden a décidé
son embargo mais il ya aussi on valoir
dans la société un débat qui est en
train de s'installer est-ce qu'il va
falloir au fond changer nos
comportements
je vous faire écouter françois hollande
lancé le débat qui est favorable à un
embargo mais vous allez le voir
aujourd'hui encore yannick jadot
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
pour europe ecologie les verts lui aussi
dans le monde signent une tribune
françois hollande en ce contexte il n'y
a qu'une décision majeure qui doit être
prise
c'est de suspendre d'arrêter les
livraisons de gaz et de pétrole
venant de russie pour l'europe c'est un
choix difficiles mais nécessaires
voilà choix difficiles mais nécessaires
il ajoute un peu plus loin que en
fonction justement des dépendances
différente des pays à la russie pour ce
qui concerne la france on pourrait
mettre en place un plan d'application
immédiate pour notre pays quitte à
laisser plus de temps nos partenaires je
ne comprends pas bien ce que propose
françois hollande est effectivement si
vous voulez travailler sur cette
dépendance il fallait pas prendre la
décision de fermeture de fessenheim en
2012 juste pour dire ce qui a été pour
rebondir sur ce qui a été dit sur le
combustible ya une partie du combustible
en parle de l'uranium de l'uranium qui
est retraité en russie mais la filière
pourrait continuer à fonctionner même
sans cette activité-là donc parler de
dépendance me semble largement abusif
c'était je précise parce qu'il m'avait
demandé de le faire moi savons que vous
êtes un porte parole mais que vous
travaillez et c'est ce qui me permet
justement est sorti sonné notamment cet
exemple nucléaire pour edf une chose qui
est certaine aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
doit avoir de nos moyens de production
des moyens de production qui nous sont
propres et c'est ce que développe le
président de la république on le fait en
se basant sur des considérations
extrêmement rationnelle qui sont en
l'occurrence les scénarios de rte dont
on a beaucoup discuté notamment sur le
plateau et de gestion des crises donc ça
passe par un développement massif
d'abord des énergies renouvelables et
par une renouvellement du parc nucléaire
historique
c'est en complément sa faim ça complète
une électrification des usages c'est à
dire qu'on va avoir besoin de plus
d'électricité pour moins dépendre du
fossile et cette électricité donc c'est
un mix entre le nucléaire et les
énergies renouvelables c'est doublement
bénéfique c'est bénéfique d'une fois
pour le climat d'une part pour le climat
et je pense qu'il faut toujours avoir ça
en tête c'est à dire que la question de
l'indépendance énergétique elle est
importante elle doit pas se faire au
détriment du climat et puis ensuite
c'est une bonne chose encore une fois
pour cette indépendance parce qu'on va
avoir des moyens de production qui nous
sont propres et aidons pas vous êtes
tous d'accord quand on ne la mèneront
pour dire qu'on va pas voilà remplacé
par une énergie fossile la culture de
guerre et qui nous permettront de
garantir notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement oui alors à anna
créty moi jamais comprendre un petit peu
au fond si le fait que la france n'a que
17 % de dépendances qu'est-ce qui se
passerait si la france le décider seul
au fond ou si on pouvait mettre un
calendrier
différencier la france sort tout de
suite du gaz et du pétrole les pays plus
dépendants ont un peu plus de temps on
verra ce que décideront les vingt-sept
on parle de diversification pas
d'embargo on a bien compris que ce
n'était pas forcément ce qu'ils allaient
sortir de ce sommet demain à versailles
mais qu'est-ce qui se passerait si la
france décidait de sortir de sa
dépendance au gaz et au pétrole russe
demain
alors demain c'est la fin du mois de
mars c'est déjà un avantage dans la
mesure où on arrive à la fin de la
période de en matière de consommation la
plus élevée donc on sort de l'hiver on
n'est pas l'abri qu'il y ait un pic deux
fois fin mars et début avril c'est déjà
arrivé
des règlements thématiques aussi
accentuant cette possibilité donc on a
déjà un allègement on va dire de
l'attention sur les volumes de gaz et
eau
qui permettrait éventuellement de faire
une plan de rationnement parce que les
17 pouces ans aujourd'hui voilà une fois
qu'on enlève un tiers des besoins dont
l'utilisation du gaz qui essaie lui
thermique on va voir comment les deux
tiers restants peuvent être
éventuellement à réorganiser mais la
réorganisation est donc le fait de dire
on se prive
d'une part des importations de gaz n'est
pas quelque chose qui peut se faire sur
vingt quatre heures
est-ce que alors là j'en profite ses
économistes sur le plateau bonsoy and
social s'y fait merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes prévisionnistes
conjoncturistes comme on dit qu'est ce
qui se passe si demain la france et là
je parle des prix et les conséquences
sur les marchés décider d'arrêter
d'acheter du gaz et du pétrole russes
alors il y aurait vraiment une hausse
très importante du prix en effet du gaz
comme vous l'avez dit on ne peut pas du
jour au lendemain comme ce a décidé
d'arrêter ça se prépare en amont c'est
ce que j'essaie de faire les pays
européens notamment l'allemagne donc il
aurait une très très très fortes hausses
de prix et donc d impact dévastateur sur
le pouvoir d'achat on voit que déjà
l'inflation est globalement énergétique
donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle on n'a
pas encore de vous par rapport aux
salaires mais c'est quand même une
inflation énergétique est très
importante parce qu'on a d'abord la
demande qui est le mondial qui est
toujours là on l'a un peu oublié mais on
est toujours dans une phase de reprise
post carriço litanie terre on devait en
avoir plus de 4% de croissance cette
année donc on est encore une demande
mondiale qui est très soutenue donc ça
d'un côté donc on pensait avoir des
tensions inflationnistes assez élevé
jusqu'à l'été et on va revenir
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure et la station
plus globalement voilà et là en plus on
a ça donc c'est sûr qu'en termes
d'énergie et de pouvoir d'achat donc il
ya un vrai coup alors là pour
relativiser parce que c'est vrai que
souvent on a moins de mémoire mais on
avait quand même gagné en pouvoir
d'achat l'année dernière en 2021 et le
quoi qu'il en coûte avec globalement
préservée aussi de pouvoir d'achat des
ménages donc on voit qu'on avait encore
un taux d par une supérieure par rapport
à ce qu'on avait en 2019 donc il y avait
de la réserve qui explique que pourquoi
l'année dernière alors qu'on a déjà eu
des hausses de prix significatives ya
pas eu d'impact sur la consommation des
ménages parce qu'il y avait la réserve
en termes d pareil là c'est vrai que si
ça continue qu'on a des hausses très
important alors un instant sur l'énergie
on viendra ensuite sur la question du
pouvoir d'achat plus globalement et sur
les prix sur l'inflation parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'on va rentrer comme en
1973 dans un choc inflationniste et sa
demande du doigté dans la réponse de
politique économique et catherine
mcgregor vous la connaissez la patronne
d'hadji qui parle très peu s'est exprimé
récemment à la fois dans la presse et
sur france inter elle explique qu on a
un peu de temps pour voir venir mais pas
tant que ça à écouter aujourd'hui nous
allons pouvoir passer l'hiver bien sûr
puisque l'hiver touche à sa fin le vrai
problème c'est ce qu'on appelle à moyen
terme c'est-à-dire pour l'hiver prochain
et pourquoi parce que on utilise l'été
pour remplir les stockages si une
décision devait être prise d'arrêtés
l'approvisionnement de la russie alors
le remplissage de ces stockages seraient
mises à mal serait insuffisant et donc
le début de l'hiver prochain
nous rions pas suffisamment gaz par
rapport aux années précédentes
là on vous parle c'est très concret un
moment donné même pour nous français
moins dépendant de là aussi ça veut dire
des black out ça veut dire des pénuries
ça veut dire un dysfonctionnement
complet du pays on peut dire ça je crois
pas mais la première chose c'est que il
faut d'abord pas perdre de vue l'agenda
climatique et la croissance dont vous
avez parlé se traduit malheureusement
par un record d'émissions de co2 mondial
donc l'agenda climatique ça tombe bien
parce que les options de réduction de
notre dépendance et donc de retrouver de
la souveraineté énergétique coincide
pour l'essentiel le nucléaire est une
exception mais pour ce qui est de la
sobriété de l'efficacité énergétique et
des renouvelables ça coïncide avec
l'agenda climatique et effectivement on
a aujourd'hui des leviers d'action
importantes dans ce domaine dont le
principal à court terme alors dans le
domaine de l'énergie je considère que
l'an prochain est plutôt du court terme
que du moyen terme mais à court terme
elle a en fait développé des
renouvelables même si il y en a dans les
tuyaux prend prend du temps l'efficacité
énergétique la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments par exemple qui est par
rapport aux enjeux dont on parle ici un
levier crucial structurelles
sobriété l'option d'une certaine façon
c'est des actions volontaires la guerre
en une même s'il a cédé à la réduction
de nos consommations il faut retrouver
l'esprit de la chasse au gaspi 1 puisque
on est dans une situation comparable au
choc pétrolier et ses actions
volontaires de réduction de la
consommation on peut parler de réduire
la limite de vitesse sur au total 110
km/heure sa économiserait d'un coup
environ 10% de l'équivalent de ce qu'on
apporte en pétrole russe on peut parler
de réduire la température moyenne de
chauffage d'un degré ce qui fait ce qui
fait 8 % on peut pas le faire partout
parce qu'il faut évidemment tenir compte
de la précarité énergétique voilà mes
degrés je m'en fous largement le calcul
qu'on a fait avec négawatt sur la base
de notre scénario à 2050 qui est pas un
scénario de
de d'action en rupture immédiate qui au
contraire un scénario lent c'est que en
sept ans par la sobriété l'efficacité et
le développement du bio gaz comme
substitution ou au gaz fossiles
importées en sept ans on peut faire des
économies ont besoin de gaz fossile plus
importante que ce qu'on importe
aujourd'hui en gaz russe bref juste pour
rebondir sur ce que disait la directrice
dnd j je pense qu'il faut expliquer aux
personnes qui nous regardent c'est qu'en
france les fournisseurs de gaz ont une
obligation de remplir d'une année sur
l'autre et les stocks de gaz ce qui
n'est pas le cas dans les autres pays ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui là où certains
pays ont des stocks qui sont quasiment
vides en france ils sont à moitié
remplie c'est un vrai levier de sécurité
d'approvisionnement et donc il est
possible que d'autres pays de l'union
européenne se tourner vers des
obligations similaires l'autre point
c'est qu'on a en france 4 terminal
méthanier alors je suis alors il faut
expliquer ce qui permet de faire venir
du gaz par d'autres modes de transport
de les gazoducs en l'occurrence opère
transport maritime et c'est ce qui
permet par exemple de réduire cette
dépendance au gaz russe qu'on fait venir
via le gazoduc on voit que c'est un peu
diminué d'ailleurs sur le gaz russe
puisque je crois qu'en 2019 on était à
24 % en france est descendue à 17 en
2021 donc je veux pas donner
l'impression de défendre le gaz mais je
crois qu'il ya aussi des moyens parce
qu'il ya des pays qui ne pourront pas
suffisamment rapidement développée que
ce soit les énergies renouvelables
nucléaire parce qu'ils n'en ont pas du
tout va trouver des alternatives ont
pour leur permettre au moins le plus
rapidement possible de se détourner de
cette de la russie dans l'import à la
crétine la france a développé des ports
des infrastructures pour faire venir du
gaz liquide notamment qui n'est pas en
russie
il faut avoir ces infrastructures là les
fameux méthanier par bateau que n'ont
pas d'autres pays je pense qu'il faut
donner un aperçu plutôt européen donc
les la construction des terminaux
méthaniers a commencé dans les années 90
et c'était un peu une sorte de
prod'homme de la libéralisation du
marché du gaz donc ça à cesser la
construction de ces infrastructures a
vraiment accompagner l'ouverture du
marché du gaz donc qui compte celui de
laiterie au gnl c'est ça ma tous les gaz
en fait est un régal ans donc on a des
marchés des changes où d'ailleurs la
russie intervient aussi elle intervenait
depuis la guerre et c'est elle n'offre
plus sur les marchés gaziers donc la
construction des infrastructures la
possibilité de recevoir du gaz liquéfié
d'autres fournisseurs internationaux
étaient en fait la réponse à
la possibilité d'ouvrir donc les marchés
du gaz à la concurrence tout en gardant
la sécurité d'approvisionnement les
problèmes de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement a été posée dès
justement des années 90 donc ce n'est
pas quelque chose qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui donc progressivement ces
terminaux ont été construits un haras
les pays aujourd'hui qu'ils allaient
plus de terminaux méthaniers et
l'espagne pour sa position évidemment
stratégique d'arrivée
du continent et de ce qu'on appelle la
partie à plein alors on se rend compte
qu'on a quand même quelques atouts dont
la difficulté mais elle a trait à sa vie
juste jose quand les gaz arrive dans un
terminal méthanier n'appartient il
n'appartient pas nécessairement au pays
sur lesquels ces terminaux est localisée
d'accra dépend du contrat qui lie à
derrière
l'approvisionnement donc ses
infrastructures facilite mais ne sont
pas quelque part propriétaire alors on a
parlé de l'offre en fait là où peut
parler de la gombe et si on réduisait
vous avez commencé à en parler ils
veulent qu'on réduise est tout
simplement la demande c'est ce débat
qu'est en train de monter en france il y
en a une sandrine rousseau vous allez
l'entendre qui a tout simplement demandé
aux français de baisser le chauffage
écouter il suffirait qu'en fait on
diminue de 2 degrés notre nos niveaux de
chauffage une au niveau de consommation
de gaz pour faire en sorte qu'on soit
sûr de tenir jusqu'à la fin de l'été et
après on verra pour la saison prochaine
deuxième chose c'est que là il faut un
plan massif urgent important une sorte
d' effort de guerre français sur
l'isolation des logements et sur rolle
l'efficacité énergétique dans les
entreprises votre région on
économiserait avec juste un degré 2° sur
des trousseaux 12 entre 12 et 15 parle
sous votre contrôle térawattheures de
gaz donc ça d'après voilà les documents
que j'ai pu lire c'est pas rien vous
êtes favorable à ce mouvement de
sobriété en fait moi l effort de guerre
alors qu'il faille passer par de la
sobriété c'est une évidence ce qui me
dérange dans le propos de sandrine
rousseau c'est que ça donne l'impression
que finalement les français se
surchauffent or il faut quand même
rappeler qu'il ya beaucoup de ménages
aujourd'hui qui ont déjà des difficultés
à payer leurs factures notamment de gaz
et qui font déjà des efforts très
importants c'est aussi le cas sur le
pétrole sur l'essence qui est utilisé
donc attention au message qu'on renvoie
là dedans et je crois que marie en
direct en de l'alcool à la grèce et ça
veut pas dire je le dis pas je ne dis
pas qu'il faut pas passer par la
sobriété c'est pas mon point je suis
allé voir papa lé là il faut fêter
modestes et les précaires qui trinquent
déjà aujourd'hui faut déjà tension
d'accord avec lui à vous excuser
aujourd'hui on évite de levier en tout
cas par rapport au gaz sur lequel il ya
un vrai effort de réduction à faire et
vous l'avez dit c'est le chauffage que
ce soit individuel ou dans les
entreprises et donc là dessus le
gouvernement l'accompagnent ces deux
milliards supplémentaires qui ont été
émis dans le cadre de ma prime rénove je
pense qu'il faut aller encore plus loin
et puis à la décor menacions de
l'industrie passé de chaudières à gaz à
des chaudières biomasse c'est ce qu'on
fait dans le cas de france 2030
développer aussi des techs et l'on sait
loin à venir comme l'hydrogène comme la
capture carbone ça prendra du temps mais
aujourd'hui et je parlais des scénarios
alerté tout à l'heure on peut avoir un
débat sur la part nerfs la part
nucléaire mais l'efficacité et la
sobriété tout porte à penser qu on n'y
coupera pas les coupera pas jean marc
jancovici et qui était sur ce plateau
disait la même chose il est pro
nucléaire et il est effectué dans un
grand un grand spécialiste la question
d'être sûr je voudrais juste vous poser
une question à crépy je vous redonne la
parole dans un instant mais tout parce
que j'ai un bug a vraiment qui me devez
vous dire on a passé toute la journée en
rédaction à se poser la question est ce
que les russes si on leur coupait le
robinet toute l'europe les américains
l'ont fait le royaume uni a emboîté le
pas est ce que ce serait efficace
est ce que au fond véritablement il ne
pourrait pas se tourner vers d'autres
pays quelle est la part dans leur
production dans leurs exportations de
l'europe en gaz russe est-ce qu'on n'ait
pas simplement en train de montrer les
muscles ou est ce que vraiment la honte
après suffisamment forte pour arrêter
financer la guerre
disons que
les conflits vue gazier ou les conflits
énergétiques vue de l'autre côté de la
frontière a les mêmes dimensions
temporelles que pour nous c'est à dire
que à court terme et il faut encore
préciser pas ce qu'est ce que c'est
c'est court terme mais en tout cas dans
l'année thermique qui vient
les géants russe gazprom a suffisamment
de réserves un bond qui sont dus à nos
achats depuis un siècle
pour se dire bon c'est six mois voilà
ils se sont déjà arrêtés du marché alors
qu'il faudrait le décider dans la durée
c'est quelque chose savoir petite
poussière dans l'oeil
mais évidemment si là
1 si on arrive à s'engager sur les moyen
terme chose qu'on aurait déjà dû faire
parce qu'on a vu quand même deux
des alertes en 2009 2014 on y avait déjà
eu des sérieux problèmes on l'a déjà
fait dans le passé avec les rangs sur le
pétrole on affaire d'embargo et oui il
l'est mais par contre les permis vite et
on va dire l'insistance avec laquelle on
consomme elle était pas au même niveau
donc l'effort et latif était différent
yves marignac courtage et interros
pgg pense effectivement que les pib
russe tient à 35% sur le fait d'avoir un
commerce international de gaz et de
pétrole tout marchés confondus est
râpeux chine et aussi une partie de
l'approvisionnement
des l'hémisphère austral
mais on parle du pib donc quelque chose
qu'on mesure d'une année sur l'autre
donc on a une fenêtre de tir limité à
court terme il faut s'engager pour les
déranger vraiment sur au moins 10 ans -
dix ans il marignac sous interrompu par
bing d'abord il faut effectivement
envoyé ces signaux de long terme c'est à
dire mettre en place les politiques et
l'efficacité thermique des bâtiments la
décarbonation de l'industrie en font
partie ça c'est des politiques qui ne se
mette en oeuvre que dans le moyen long
terme il faut envoyer ces signaux la
envoyer les signaux de fort
développement des renouvelables pour
dire que d'ici 2050 ou même avant la
france l'europe peuvent être totalement
indépendant énergétiquement sur la base
d'énergies locales maîtrisé sans enjeu
de 2,2 voilà de dépendances
de même type aujourd'hui dans l'immédiat
la seule option vraiment disponible
c'est effectivement la sobriété la
sobriété je suis complètement d'accord
c'est pas quelque chose qu'il faut
appliquer de manière uniforme la
sobriété l'association négawatt en parle
depuis longtemps c'est une intelligence
du hc réduire les consommations
d'énergie là où elles ne rendent pas
suffisamment de service et donc ça
existe
ça veut dire que typiquement il ne faut
pas obliger tout le monde à ne plus
prendre sa voiture là où des gens sont
totalement dépendants de leur véhicule
pour cent dans les grandes villes faut
mettre en place il faut mettre en place
de l'offre de transports publics de
l'offre de mobilité douce mais ça prend
du temps par contre la plupart d une
majorité des déplacements de moins de 2
km aujourd'hui
typiquement domicile travail se font en
voiture là il ya un levier évident de
transfert vers la mobilité douce qui
n'est pas de la privation qui est le
fait de retrouver pour les ménages de la
liberté de choix et surtout ses actions
sobriété dont on parle qui peuvent être
des actions volontaires et accompagnés
sont des actions qui sont bénéfiques en
même temps du point de vue à la fois du
pouvoir d'achat et du coût global de
l'énergie pour la collectivité et par
rapport aux enjeux économiques c'est
évidemment essentiel tout en étant
encore une fois il ne faut pas le perdre
de vue aligné avec l'urgence climatique
on a compris que la guerre en ukraine et
le climat pour être même combat on a
compris aussi que demain à versailles on
va parler diversification mais pas
embargo ça c'est très clair parce que
déjà le plan de la commission européenne
c'est de réduire de deux tiers et c'est
déjà beaucoup si on y arrive en un an
les livraisons de gaz russe je vous
donne la parole tout de suite and social
c'est parce que maintenant on va
s'arrêter sur votre expertise on
comprend que les prix de l'énergie
flambent à nouveau et encore plus depuis
l'invasion l'invasion russe de l'ukraine
à quoi peut-on s'attendre
bruno le maire a sorti une phrase qui
nous a interpellés aujourd'hui on va la
réentendre dans ce sujet signé marc
anthony
les prix de l'essence en vol plus de
deux euros le litre dans de nombreuses
stations en france
carburants électricité gaz
tous les prix de l'énergie flambent et
le ministre de l'économie n'était pas
rassurant ce matin ce n'est pas exagéré
que de dire que cette crise énergétique
ce choc énergétique de 2022 est
comparable en intensité en brutalité au
choc pétrolier de 1973 le choc pétrolier
de 1973 à l'époque les pays du
moyen-orient membres de l'opep décide
d'augmenter le prix du baril conséquence
du soutien de certains pays occidentaux
à israël en guerre contre une coalition
de pays arabes un choc pétrolier aux
conséquences négatives sur l'économie
en 1975 la france est en récession le
taux de chômage passe de 3 à 6 % en 1980
l'inflation elle avoisine les 10% par an
et les consommateurs se plaignaient déjà
de l'envolée des prix
en 2022 c'est la guerre en ukraine qui
aggravent l'envolée des prix de
l'énergie des prix qui ont augmenté de
21 % sur les douze derniers mois le
gouvernement doit présenter la semaine
prochaine son plan de résilience
économique et social on est déjà en
train de protéger les français on les
protège sur l'électricité on les protège
sur le gaz et on va prolonger la
protection le bouclier gaz
jusqu'à la fin de l'année donc on prend
des mesures sur le carburant ça fait
partie du fameux plan de résilience que
le premier ministre va annoncer pour
aider les ménages emmanuel macron a
confirmé lundi les pistes d'une
indemnité inflation et d'une
revalorisation de l'indemnité
kilométrique
le gouvernement prévoit aussi des
mesures pour les entreprises les plus
impactés par la guerre notamment les
filières de l'aéronautique ou de
l'agriculture mais bruno le maire
prévient pas question de mettre en place
un second quoi qu'il en coûte cette
réponse alimenterez l'augmentation des
prix selon le ministre de l'économie en
1973 cette réponse a provoqué le choc
inflationniste que vous connaissez
conduit des banques centrales pour
lutter contre ce choc inflationniste à
augmenter massivement les taux ce qui
avait tué la croissance cela porte un
nom la stagflation pour le gouvernement
la seule bonne réponse sur le long terme
restent l'indépendance énergétique
totale de la france et de l'union
européenne
and social cif c'est quelque chose
qu'aucun économistes avaient anticipé
cette inflation et qui va à nouveau on
s'attend vraiment à de fortes
augmentations
est-ce que vous pouvez nous décrire ce
qui va se passer très concrètement pour
les ménages français consomment qu'est
ce qui va augmenter et de combien
alors
réponse difficile en effet ce qu'on fait
des prévisions on ne peut pas savoir en
effet exactement puisque personne
n'avait anticipé cette crise personne
n'avait anticipé prise en partie
inflationnistes actuelles qu'ovide et là
évidemment la guerre
concernant la crise donc sanitaire en
effet ce qu'il faut se rappeler avant la
crise sanitaire c'est qu'on était dans
une dans des politiques monétaires et
budgétaires très faim surtout monétaire
très accommodante 1 pendant dix ans
depuis la crise de 2008 et qu'on était
en situation de très faible inflation
voir déflation on a eu la crise
sanitaire on a eu de quoi qu'il en coûte
pour avoir cette relance on a eu de
l'inflation en france mais encore une
fois attention on en a eu parce qu'avant
n'en avait pas et on était à des niveaux
qui était soutenable au
dessus des 2% et cette année avant la
crise grecque avant la crise du crédit
on était plutôt autour de 2
214 d'accord donc ça c'était la
situation avant je pense qu'il faut
vraiment faire la part des choses et ça
en effet il avait quand même anticipé
parce qu'on sait que quand on est une
reprise en même temps que ces
importantes c'est normal que ce soit
inflationnistes donc s'ils voulaient en
revenait dans une situation un petit peu
normal
aujourd'hui donc ça ça on est au
mensuel par rapport à l'année n - 1
pourquoi parce qu'en effet c'est dans
cette inflation on a vraiment ce fameux
prix de l'énergie donc c'est ça aussi
qui est très important de voir c'est
vraiment une inflation énergétique c'est
pas une inflation par rapport au salaire
quand on l'a par rapport par exemple aux
états unis qui sont dans cette situation
973 et sert de nouveau dans la situation
a des effets sur ce coup les bienvenus
effet les prix tout à fait on à l'effet
rattrapage posco vide et on a l'effet
crise du crédit et donc en effet on va
vraiment avoir cette inflation très
importantes conduit par l'énergie ont
crû de lait produit alors concrètement
non pas sur tous les produits ce qui va
vraiment être impactés s'en défende a
dit l'étang réalimente air est en effet
tout ce qui est énergie donc là c'est
pour ça aussi que ça va créer beaucoup
d'inégalités que les politiques
économiques à mettre en oeuvre sont très
importantes parce qu'il faut vraiment au
lieu de saupoudrer tout le monde
vraiment voir qu'il est aussi à l'écouté
et ciblée massivement pour justement
qu'il n'y ait pas trop de la garde est
d'accord avec bruno le maire donc ça il
faut vraiment regarder en container
vraiment voilà c'est une inflation
énergétique et qui n'est pas globale et
l'autre élément c'est une fois qu'on a
fait ce constat là et c'est plus
difficile en a parlé précédemment avec
la transition écologique il va y avoir
une hausse des prix des biens
manufacturés
c'est indéniable pourquoi aussi parce
que bien sûr on doit faire la transition
donc il y aura un côté destruction et
toutes les entreprises qui vont voir
leurs processus industriels donc là il y
aura encore une fois une hausse des prix
l'autre élément qu'on voit depuis 2008
c'est la hausse du protectionnisme
quand on va mettre la taxe carbone aux
frontières justement pour protéger notre
archer dire on veut que telle ou telle
norme les autres l'ont fait rossi l'a
jamais lu seulement ce niveau des
carburants c'est la taxe carbone c'est
comme si elle était mise mais ce que je
lis d'écossé oasis doivent être rebelle
situé sur les inflationniste va
continuer on va aller vers une hausse et
de l'énergie et des biens manufacturiers
pendant valant la nature les voitures
mais le vôtre immobilier votre chaîne
hi-fi et votre grave alimentaire c'est
aussi l'ensemble des exactement eh bien
il faut conjoncturellement on aura
surtout une prise d'eau de l'énergie et
des denrées alimentaires qui peuvent
aller de 10 20 30 % en fonction des
fluctuations de la crise grecque et de
la volonté des marchés et à moyen long
terme avec la transition écologique dans
la première phase il y aura une hausse
des prix des biens manufacturiers pas de
hausse des salaires globale commençait
supportable parce qu'on se voit bien on
comprend bien le processus mais c'est
pas moche brégeon hull et l'échec
inflation des mesures ciblées on voit
bien qu'on est dans un mouvement
inflationnistes
je crois qu'il faut faire les deux en
fait d'une part il faut faire des
mesures très court terme curative
d'accompagnement c'est ce qu'on fait
quand on bloque avec le tarif le
bouclier tarifaire sur le gaz sur
l'électricité avec la hausse des
indemnités kilométriques avait envoyé
vers elle a déjà presque mais c'est
effectivement des mesures qui sont
encore une fois curative et en parallèle
il ya tout ce travail vous avez raison
bien sûr les salaires et c'est ce qu'on
a commencé à faire depuis 2010 est de
faire en sorte que le travail paie mieux
revaloriser le minimum vieillesse
travailler sur ce pouvoir d'achat là je
crois que c'est un c'est encore une fois
sûr c'est une action globale et puis re
disons le on se répète mais je pense que
c'est important sortir du fossile et
aller vers un mix entre le nucléaire et
les énergies renouvelables
c'est quand même ce qui économiquement
coûtera le margeur à l'antenne or même
en huit ans mais je vous dis il faut de
nouvelles centrales il faudrait pas
devenu 1,42 donner l'impression en
gagnerait à rester dans le fossile
d'amour vous avez le mot de la fin ça
débat s'achève and social s'ils n'ont
bien évidemment il ya ces efforts et
donc en a parlé mais là encore il faut
être vraiment excessivement clairs c'est
l'aspect prix et puis tout se dire il
faut modifier son comportement etc de
toute façon l'aspect prix qui fait que
les prix vont énormément augmenter son
fonds que vous allez changer vos
comportements donc ça il faut pas
vraiment le il faut pas le mine
lumineuse minimiser et l'autre élément
c'est sur les salaires attention le but
c'est justement qu'on est pas et d'une
inflation énergétique qui passe une
inflation générale de au général des
prix des salaires et qu'on soit
justement dans une dans un stade très
imparfaite en avant ou là les politiques
monétaires dont justement être moins
accommodante et on va casser la reprise
dont on a vraiment besoin merci père
aussi attention à ça tout petit message
je vois que vous faites jamais vraiment
compté c'est à dire un des moyens de
contrer l'effet prix c'est de travailler
sur l'effet volume consommé donc
sobriété efficacité sont là aussi par le
biais cruciaux merci beaucoup vous
restez avec nous parce qu'on va écouter
tous ensemble le carnet de campagne
parce qu'on ouvre une page
présidentielle après tout elle elle est
toujours en cours on va on va s'arrêter
ce soir on commence avec look de blake
au en est à j - 33 avant le premier tour
stéphane blakowski son carnet de
campagne qu'on a quelques doutes
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane je disais mon tabouret
je suis tombé
on est bien on est serrés tapez 3 mais
sympathique bonsoir à toutes et à tous
est ce qui a attiré votre oeil ce soir
ben je veux dire que ce matin j'ai eu un
choc parce que figurez-vous que en
allumant vendre mon ordinateur j'ai cru
que valérie pécresse était en tête du
classement des sondages je suis dit
tiens c'est bizarre quand même en
regardant mieux je me suis en fait que
c'était pas le classement des sondages
c'était classement des patrimoines et de
fête valérie pécresse est largement en
tête voyait là presque 10 millions
d'euros de patrimoine dire qu'elle a
presque autant dans sa tirelire que
l'ensemble des autres candidats qu'on
apprend des choses avec ce classement
est ce qu'on apprend des choses pas
vraiment vous allez ça suscite des
commentaires des comparaisons se rend
compte que le candidat du peuple par
exemple est plus riche que le président
des riches donc voilà ça surprend mais à
ceux qui regardaient en détail des
commandes ils se sont rendus compte que
putôt avait une voiture qui écoutait
plus chère que celle de valérie pécresse
vont on s'amuse comme on peut hein parce
que vous savez quels sont les candidats
qui n'ont pas de voiture a alors pour
voilà il a le goût évidemment mais aussi
macron mélenchon zemmour le pen tout le
monde ne fait pas le plein voyez mais
enfin si on veut rester sérieux la seule
chose à retenir mon avis est que tous
les candidats qui se présentent sont en
fait beaucoup plus riche que la majorité
des français j'ai pris les chiffres de
l'observatoire des inégalités voyez pour
un adulte on va arriver et bien je vous
lis si vous ne le voyez pas encore à la
moitié des français ont un patrimoine
qui est inférieur 94 1250 euros c'est à
dire que le candidat à la présidentielle
le plus pauvre philippe poutou est
toujours deux fois plus riche que bas
les français moyens ça qu'on fait donc
des quotas pour que les femmes soient
mieux représentés à la société c'est une
très bonne idée est-ce qu'on devrait pas
faire des quotas pour que les classes
populaires soient mieux représentés dans
la société est-ce qu'on lance le débat
non
ce qui donc un défaut
ban qui était en tête dans le classement
au patrimoine mais en revanche dans les
sondages c'est pas ça elle a encore
perdu des points cela dit donc myriam
enfin virginie ça comme si c'est de sa
faute
c'est qu'elle fait une mauvaise campagne
peut-être ne soyez pas injustes
vous êtes très bien que si valérie
pécresse se dégringole dans les sondages
c'est pas de sa faute vous savez pas que
ce n'est pas de sa faute elle l'a dit ce
matin sur bfm portant écoutez je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la guerre en ukraine
écrase tout elle écrase cette campagne
elle écrase notamment le débat
démocratique qui doit avoir lieu sur
l'état de la france est aujourd'hui ya
s'il ya un réflexe légitimiste vis-à-vis
du président de la république est bon
alors elle prend des risques quand même
puisque demain soir elle sera face à
eric zemmour dans un dans un débat sur
tf1 lci ouais elle pourrait même
peut-être sortir gagnante la saison
qu'elle n'est pas favorite mais elle
s'en était bien tiré au débat de la
primaire chekade public un bon le
problème c'est que effectivement zemmour
risque d'être un peu plus coriace que
michel barnier ça évidemment la même
dire qu'ils s'inquiètent pour garder
pécresse qui disent mais attention ce
n'est pas prudent la laissez pas les
débattre avec zemmour et dans quel état
elle va sortir du ring on écoute renaud
muselier qui est un excellent air qui a
rejoint président macro et profilé
pécresse sera demain soir face à eric
zemmour en débat c'est un quitte ou
double pour elle elle va se faire
massacrer senki tout court ah bon voilà
je viens vous ne vous présentez pas à
droite culturellement on doit réussir
nos meetings c'est un moment de fête de
l'ess elle l'a raté et il ya un truc qui
ne faut pas faire ça elle se présentait
sur le terme polémiste qui fait ça
depuis dix ans matt hamill issaurat
télévision c'est comme si vous mettiez
un étudiant en médecine face à nouveau
changé en 10 ans quel est le meilleur
pur jeu le crâne votre patient est bien
là sont massacrés elle va se faire
massacrer massacrer
mais il tire quand même sur les
ambulances non non ça ne se tait par nos
noms dont on ne fait pas ce genre de
choses alors c'est lui qui monte en
revanche ça peut être une surprise après
ses propos sur ta dès mercredi c'est
jean luc mélenchon a fait remarquer vous
aussi celui qui monte c'est mélenchon
mais ce n'est pas le remède pas la seule
puisque jadot rosell hidalgo l'on
remarqué aussi du coup ils ont beau
l'accusé de d'être pro russe s'élèveront
le reproche qu'on lui fait en ce moment
quand on regarde les sondages finalement
mélenchon c'est le seul candidat de la
gauche aujourd'hui qui est susceptible
d'affronter
au second tour nous a quand même un
petit bémol c'est que ce matin invité
son france info alexis corbière a fait
une gaffe il a parlé des armes qu'on
vivrait d'ukraine il en a dit plus que
ce qu'il fallait dire alors on s'est
renseigné puisqu'on est à l'assemblée
alexis corbière n'est pas à limite
habilité secret défense dont il n'a pas
pu révéler le secret défense mon fils a
dit un peu plus que prévu en écoute vous
parlez des armes françaises franchement
cd gilet pare-balles et quelques
missiles antichars mais pour qu'elle
avait la liste vous des parts dont vous
avez la liste des armes fournies par la
france eh bien je vais vous dire je
siège à la commission défense et armé je
ne vois pas vous dire ben vous c'est
pour ça que je vous pose la question
parce qu'on ne la connais pas vous ne
nous l'a donnée vous pouvez nous disent
ça peut ressembler à ça oui bon bah
voilà c'est une gaffe quoi c'est pas
alors évidemment ses adversaires n'ont
pas pris sur ce ton là il est vrai par
deux pays vont entamer d'abriel est elle
pour le gouvernement et puis fabien
roussel pour parti communiste ont pointé
c'est sa légèreté son inconséquence en
se bougeant suggérant même qu'il devait
le jeu des russes mais en fait je ne
suis pas vraiment c'est pas un secret
défense c'est un secret de polichinelle
europe 1 avait déjà dit qu'ils avaient
des 1000 des missiles antichars le monde
a republié un papier cet après midi donc
en fait si on tape sans mélenchon c'est
peut-être parce que celui qui montrent
justement voyez on se dira et ennuyeux
cette campagne se passe rien mais en
revanche si mélenchon se qualifie pour
le second tour ça c'est une surprise ça
c'est une campagne inattendu bon bah
merci pour ce regard ce ton décalé votre
région attention à l'excès de confiance
parce qu emmanuel macron certes est
favori et il a même bondi dans les
sondages vous savez où sont les
parlementaires ce soir surtout du
candidat emmanuel macron absolument
stéphanie des pierres est avec nous en
duplex je crois que vous êtes dans le
12e arrondissement
impossible évidemment pour le le
candidat de recevoir sa majorité ses
troupes à l'elysée il y a une sale
j'imagine qui a été loué pour l'occasion
est ce qu'on en sait un petit peu plus
sur les échanges du président-candidat
du candidat-président avec avec sa
majorité avec les députés
oui mais rim emmanuel macron est arrivé
vers 19h15 dans cette salle du 12e
arrondissement il a a sonné la
mobilisation générale
il a remercié les députés pour leur
engagement et il a véritablement lancé
la campagne devant la majorité réunis il
ya jean castex le premier ministre mais
aussi à françois bayrou du modem edouard
philippe il a invectivé il a harangué
les députés et leur a demandé de porter
son projet politique qui doit être
marqué selon ses mots par la dureté du
moment mais aussi par une ambition
renouvelée il a réitéré sa proposition
de supprimer la redevance
télévisuelle il a également parlé de son
ambition de réformer les retraites mais
il n'a pas donné d'âge il n'a pas parlé
de cet âge à 65 ans contrairement à ce
que les échos le journal les echos a
publié ce soir il n'a donc pas confirmé
cette information et il a insisté auprès
des députés nous devons nous battre pour
le meilleur score soyez à des
combattants jusqu'à la dernière seconde
rien est acquis il a rappelé qu'avant le
second tour avant les législatives et
bien il y avait d'abord le premier tour
de cette présidentielle
et dès demain emmanuel macron reprendra
ses habits de président pour le sommet
des chefs d'état européens qui est
prévue à versailles merci beaucoup
stéphanie des pierres en duplex donc du
12e arrondissement ça n'est pas plié je
suis sûr que vous êtes d'accord sur tout
même pas afficher de trop d'excès de
confiance c'est l'idée merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir participé à ce débat nous
on continue à parler de cette campagne
avec notre nouveau rendez-vous des
chroniqueurs qui viennent chaque soir
passé au crible en fait comparer un
geste une image un candidat ça s'appelle
le scan regarder
mais avant l'e3 il y aller devant pas de
fatalité au grand remplacement
et bien molle vous propose le rouge
d'helmand d'agir pour le climat
l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
un bail aux travailleurs le système bose
exclu il ya un vrai problème de pouvoir
d'achat rendre à la france sa grandeur
d'arrêt ça sert pas mystère c'est le bol
et bonsoir à nos nouveaux chroniqueurs
ou visages familiers alors commencer par
les nouveaux mariés darrigand bonsoir on
est ravis de vous accueillir vous êtes
sémiologue et régulièrement une fois par
semaine vous allez comme ça essayer de
nous livrer votre regard sur un geste un
mot une sémantique une image dans cette
campagne bonsoir benjamin grange bonsoir
rien des réseaux sociaux sociaux ne vous
échappe vous êtes président de mascaret
qui travaille notamment sur les
réactions sur les différents réseaux
sociaux en lien avec le politique mais
on va commencer avec notre ami vincent
vincent et je grand reporter qui va
s'essayer à la chronique politique se
soit vous nous parler d'eric zemmour qui
a bien du mal à se défaire de ses
déclarations sur sur l'a10 mire poutine
et qui paye tout cela dans les sondages
bah oui parce qu'il arrive toujours un
moment où la logomachie électoraliste
vient se fracasser sur le mur du réel et
pourrait aisément cette douloureuse
collision a été hâtée par l'invasion
brutale de l'ukraine depuis l'histrion
de reconquête se livrent à des
contorsions oratoire qui ferait les
délices d'un congrès de sémiologue de
séminaires de psychanalyste lacanien
celui qui rêvait à voix haute d'un
poutine français celui qui dans un tweet
datée de septembre 2000 vins élevés la
sainte russie à la dignité d'allier la
plus fiable de la france celui qui
serait réel trois ans plus tôt dé payer
son idole sous les traits de l'homme à
poigne qui viendra un jour sauver
l'europe chrétienne il en perd son latin
et son logiciel il faut dire que ce cher
vlady ne lui facilitent pas la tâche lui
le protecteur de la chrétienté en péril
mise sur les soudards de son vassal
tchétchène ramzan kadirov pour terrasser
la résistance des frères slaves
orthodoxes comme catholiques dieu pour
vous qu'il en trouve reconnaîtra les
siens
contorsions sémantiques disions-nous
morceaux choisis tient en date du 2 mars
le mâle alpha est certes pas bêta du
kremlin qualifié l'avant-veille de
démocrates autoritaires amis de
l'oxymore bonsoir se voit relégué au
rang de seul agresseur même si je cite
encore le coupable c'est poutine le
responsable c'est l'occident qui n'a
cessé de pardon c'est l'occident et
l'otan surtout cessé de s'étendre la
variante inversée du fameux responsable
pas coupable le coupable irresponsable
le même fort sur ces news aux surprises
on eu droit à ce distinguo déroutants
entre le patriotisme héroïque du
président ukrainien volodimir céline ce
qui est le patriotisme agressif de
l'ancien officier du kgb même si tous
deux sont des êtres rationnels qui
défendent leur pays enfin leur pays ou
ce qui en reste s'agissant de zeyneb ski
mais qu'on se rassure notre imprécateur
tacconi d'un traité de paix reposant sur
la neutralité de l'ukraine associés
défense de rire au respect de
l'intangibilité de ses frontières alors
sur le registre de la casuistique à 3
kopecks il y à mieux car la conversion
que dis-je la peau stasi de zemmour le
poutine lattre paraît rien erratique et
elle ne s'étend pas aux cohortes de
réfugiés d'ukrainiens dans son immense
mansuétude
le polémiste qu'on sorte à les
accueillir mais en pologne je vous ouvre
ma porte vous restez sur le pas ou mieux
encore à l'autre bout de la rue en
filigrane cette distinction très chers à
l'extrême droite entre le bon réfugiés
blanc fils de la vieille europe et de
culture chrétienne et l'indésirable le
musulmans syriens ou afghans à
propos d' afghanistan et en ce lendemain
de 8 mars journée un talent des droits
des femmes bref retour sur le verdict du
prince eric quant à l'éventuel azim
octroyés aux civils menacés par la
tyrannique talibane c'était le 12 mars
sur bfm
je cite les afghanes ne sont pas des
combattants de la liberté pour moi donc
je ne les accepte pas elles restent chez
elles bien si celles qui osent défier
les nouveaux maîtres de kaboul ne mérite
pas ce label d'un soumises alors qui
donc en est digne alors un scoop pour
terminer
non non non ce z énigmatique pas sur les
blindés russes ne signifie pas zemmour
mais sans doute zapad vers l'ouest ce
qui revient à peu près au même car pour
ce qui est d'être à l'ouest
merci toujours très bien écrit ses
chroniques de de vincent et je vous
allez nous parler aussi benjamin granger
c'est la transition des réfugiés deux
millions de réfugiés déjà vous avez
regardez un peu comment les français
accueillait cette question voilà de
l'accueil des réfugiés et est également
comment les candidats se se positionnait
ça change tout et ça bouscule a à
nouveau la campagne oui alors déjà faut
savoir que l'ukraine c'est le sujet le
plus discuté par les français sur les
réseaux sociaux et quand on parle des
réfugiés c'est un peu aujourd'hui
l'union sacrée comme au moment du séisme
en haïti en août 2010 21 alors l'arrivée
des réfugiés est vécue par les français
comme un moment de solidarité peut-être
issus d'ailleurs de la tradition
humaniste française on est dans un
moment plein d'émotion d'empathie alors
les on multiplie les photos sur les
réseaux sociaux sur les pauvres réfugiés
sur la manière dont il s'exile de leur
pays avec beaucoup d'image alors il ya
notamment des images en france sur la
manière dont ils sont accueillis sur le
port de marseille au total c'est presque
51 mille messages qui depuis le 21
février tourne finalement finalement en
boucle avec une même tonalité pour
l'instant des messages chaleureux et
aucune voix divergentes en tous cas de
manière extrêmement minoritaire alors
même si certains médias relatent que des
réfugiés un peu opportuniste se serait
glissée dans ces flux dans ces flux
migratoires ukrainien eh bien ça ne fait
même pas mouche au niveau des français
qui ne voient même pas le point alors
pourquoi me diriez vous et bien
simplement parce qu après la sidération
parce qu'après la stupeur associés à
cette crise s'est installée une forme de
deuxième étape au niveau de la
population avec une perception très
manichéenne de deux camps cette
situation la russie d'un côté fait face
à la communauté internationale en contre
de l'autre passager nerfs avant tout de
la pitié pour le peuple ukrainien vue
comme la seule est la première victime
donc non l'ukraine n'est absolument pas
perçue comme un pays proche de l'europe
ou proches de la france évidemment pour
les français mais cela ne bride pas
les longs qui quitte à celui qu'on a
observés au moment de haïti ou de
l'accident à fukushima alors vous face à
tous à tout cela comment les politiques
se positionnent on sent que ton juste
n'est pas toujours au rendez vous oui
c'est très difficile de trouver le ton
juste il ya tout d'abord ceux qui
s'accordent à partager en fait cette
volonté d'accueil affichée par
l'exécutif donc on reste finalement dans
l'union sacrée est la conséquence
évidemment logique ils sont inaudibles
on en parle absolument pas sur les
réseaux sociaux dans une campagne déjà
sur lequel il est compliqué d'arriver à
mettre en avant ses messages alors après
vous avez marine le pen qui déclarait ne
pas penser du tout que vladimir poutine
soit un fou avant de finalement de deux
nuances et quelques jours après qu'il a
eu tort d'envahir l'ukraine est ce que
véritablement ça a fait changer les
lignes au niveau des internautes pas
tellement ses sympathisants ces
sympathisants acquiesce ses opposants ne
réagissent pas finalement pas beaucoup
de réactions quant à eric zemmour fidèle
à sa ligne qui déclarait je ne veux pas
d'un tsunami migratoire ukrainien fondée
sur l'émotion c'est le seul d'ailleurs
qu'à relever que l'on était dans un très
grand moment d'émotion là encore pas
beaucoup de bruit au delà de son camp
alors il ya un grand gagnant gagnant
c'est clairement fait emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron qui quand on regarde les
conversations sur l'ukraine si peut-être
en régie on peut les on peut les voir
voit le nuage de mots avec l'ensemble
des conversations qu'on a sur les guides
sur l'ukraine en europe et en france
c'est à peu près le même nuage de mots
on s'aperçoit que on trouve deux
protagonistes phare évidemment vla de
vladimir poutine mais emmanuel macron et
puis la présidente de la commission
européenne est en fait la stature
présidentielle aujourd'hui elles portent
le candidat macron après le coït qui a
maintenu son image de chef pendant la
crise cette nouvelle crise la pérennise
donc pour lui rien n'a changé merci
merci benjamin mariette darrigrand vous
vouliez revenir sur un mot le mot de
guerre on dit souvent que la politique
et les campagnes selon martial tous unis
derrière le chef avec la guerre
l'invasion russe de l'ukraine les choses
ne peuvent plus être la même manière sur
le plan sémantique exactement gérer que
c'est peut-être la seule bonne nouvelle
de la période qui est si noir si sombre
c'est que je crois nous allons échapper
à la métaphore de la guerre et donc la
guerre la dea en démocratie comme chacun
sait la guerre continue et par d'autres
moyens et donc la guerre devient
métaphorique et alors là pendant les
campagnes électorales évidemment on a
une espèce de déploiement de cette
dimension martial des chefs alors
continue sur eric zemmour vous l'avez
très bien montré c'est ridicule il ya
une posture aujourd'hui qui paraît
ridicule au regard du réel donc on ne
peut plus être un défenseur de la patrie
au sens je dirais presque télévisuelle
médiatique quand il y a évidemment en
face de nous des gens qui le font mais
avec dans le réel des choses il y avait
qu un vrai courage à batterie en
craignant montre le courage voilà alors
qu'est ce que ça fait pour notre
vocabulaire politique de la
présidentielle y en a des métaphores de
la guerre notre président je crois qu'on
a le le sont peut-être quand il nous a
parlé au début de la crise due qu'au
guide de guerre il nous a dit nous
sommes en guerre il a été fort critique
et déjà c'est bien le signe que nous ils
ne sont pas c'est pas forcément légitime
de brandir une exagération une hyperbole
comme on dit en sémiologie lorsque
justement il ya de la souffrance dans le
réel mais ils le font tous nos
politiques parce que c'est une façon de
s'autoproclamer chef de s'auto valorisé
si vous voulez surtout dans notre pays
nous avons une grande figure tutélaire
qui est charles de gaulle mais ça je
crois que c'est ben nous sommes le 9
mars donc je peux encore être un peu
féministe je crois que c'est une manière
de regarder dans le rétro en vraie
politique contemporaine aujourd'hui il
ya d'autres figurent d'autres manières
de gouvernance qui sait si elles
viennent des femmes et il ya au môle
d'avis bien aux juges il ya deux femmes
présidentes wiki on est payés qui ont
beaucoup de courage qui sont aussi
guerrière au sens de la bravoure que les
hommes mais qui essaie une autre
gouvernance et ça je crois que c'est
vraiment la chose qui nous fera un peu
espéré pour pour la suite
grand pardon vous avez entendu la
musique de fin pour cette chronique est
courte et j'espère vivement que vous
reviendrez
merci à vous trois c'est la fin de cette
émission rendez vous demain même lieu
même heure ici la très belle soirée
documentaire sur lcp
[Musique]